This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthu. When the New York Times showed that Donald Trump may have used a legal loophole to avoid paying federal income taxes for years, many people expected the self-destribe billionaire to be embarrassed. Instead, in a debate with Hillary Clinton, Donald Trump said, He didn't pay any federal income tax. So, if he paid zero, that means zero. That makes me smart. It got us thinking about a new book by Brooke Harrington, a sociologist at the Copenhagen Business School in Denmark.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当《纽约时报》披露唐纳德·特朗普可能利用法律漏洞多年来逃避缴纳联邦所得税时，许多人原本以为这位自命不凡的亿万富翁会感到尴尬。然而，在与希拉里·克林顿的辩论中，唐纳德·特朗普却表示，他没有支付任何联邦所得税。所以，如果他支付了零，那就意味着零。这说明我很聪明。这让我们想起了丹麦哥本哈根商学院社会学家布鲁克·哈灵顿的一本新书。
She decided several years ago to explore the secret lives of billionaires. She took an unusual path to enter this world. She herself trained to become a wealth manager. In the course of this training, she gained unprecedented access to other wealth managers who agreed to be interviewed for her research. She discovered that in order to manage money for the super rich, these professionals also learn a lot about the private lives of their clients. What they shared, Brooke says, shocked her.
几年前，她决定探索亿万富翁们的秘密生活。她走了一条不同寻常的道路来进入这个世界。她亲自接受了成为一名财富管理师的培训。在培训过程中，她获得了前所未有的机会，能够接触到其他同意接受她研究采访的财富管理师。她发现，为了替超级富豪管理资金，这些专业人士同时也深入了解了客户的私人生活。布鲁克说，他们所分享的内容震惊了她。
The lives of the richest people in the world are so different from those of the rest of us. It's almost literally unimaginable. National borders are nothing to them. They might as well not exist. The laws are nothing to them. They might as well not exist. The laws are nothing to them. They might as well not exist. Today on Hidden Brain, the sociology and psychology of some members of the billionaire class and the professionals who enable them. Brooke Harrington, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me on the show.
世界上最富有的人的生活与我们普通人的生活有着天壤之别。简直可以说是无法想象。国境对他们来说毫无意义。它们几乎可以说是不存在的。法律对他们来说毫无意义。它们几乎可以说是不存在的。法律对他们来说毫无意义。它们几乎可以说是不存在的。今天在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨亿万富翁阶层中某些成员以及为他们提供便利的专业人士的社会学和心理学。布鲁克·哈灵顿，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你邀请我参加节目。
For wealth managers to do their job, Brooke, I understand that they need to find out everything about a client's life, not just a client's financial life, but everything about their life. Give me some examples of the kind of conversations people have with wealth managers and the kind of issues they bring up about their personal circumstances that might affect how their wealth is managed. Well, it usually starts with what's called know your client activity. So, if you were to come to me with me acting as the wealth manager, I would first ask to see some proof of identity like your
布鲁克，为了让财富管理师能够开展工作，据我所能理解的，他们需要了解客户生活的方方面面，不仅是客户的财务状况，而是生活的方方面面。能给我举几个例子，说说人们会与财富管理师进行什么样的对话，以及他们会提出哪些可能影响其财富管理方式的个人情况问题吗？嗯，这通常从所谓的“了解你的客户”活动开始。所以，如果你来找我，由我担任你的财富管理师，我首先会要求看一些身份证明，比如你的
passport. And then we would talk about what goals you had for your wealth, and that begins the series of increasingly delicate and increasingly intrusive questions. Then usually we get into whatever real reason is bringing you to me. Maybe you want to avoid your taxes. Maybe you really don't like your family. That's surprisingly common among wealthy people. For example, if you have a relative or if you yourself are engaging in some activity that might get you extorted, it may not be illegal, but it might be socially shameful.
护照。然后我们会谈谈你对你的财富有什么目标，这就拉开了接连提出的一系列越来越微妙、越来越具侵入性的问题的序幕。接下来，我们通常会谈到你来找我的真正原因。也许你想避税。也许你真的很讨厌你的家庭。这在富人当中出奇地普遍。例如，如果你有一个亲戚，或者你自己正在从事某种可能遭到敲诈的活动，这可能不违法，但可能会在社会上让人感到羞耻。
That's a financial risk that your wealth manager needs to know about. If you have a son or daughter with a drug problem, that's a financial risk that your wealth manager needs to know about. There can also be issues like, I think I'm headed for a divorce, but I don't want my spouse to get half my assets. How do I hide those assets? Preferably offshore, so that whatever is legally provable as mine is such a small amount that it's not worth fighting about. So it's really interesting because these professionals in some ways get to know their clients better than the client's own family or friends or even their own spouse? Yes, it's apparently something of a cliche in the offshore
这是你的财富管理师需要了解的财务风险。如果你有一个吸毒的儿子或女儿，这也是你的财富管理师需要了解的财务风险。还可能会有一些问题，比如，我觉得我要离婚了，但我不想让配偶分走我的一半资产。我该如何隐藏这些资产？最好是藏在海外，这样在法律上能证明属于我的财产只有微不足道的一点，根本不值得为之争夺。所以这真的很有趣，因为这些专业人士在某些方面甚至比客户自己的家人、朋友、甚至是他们自己的配偶还要了解客户？是的，在海外
world that the average client is a man in his 50s with a secret family somewhere. Might be a gay lover, might be a common law wife and some children, but they're usually all sorts of secrets that these wealthy folks wish to keep hidden and that they have the additional privilege of being able to hire people to take care of in secret. So I understand you conducted about 65 interviews in 18 countries for this book. Tell me a little bit about the people you met. To be a wealth manager you have to understand finance and the law, but this kind of role also calls for a certain psychological makeup. What kind of person becomes a wealth manager?
世界里这似乎成了一种老生常谈的 clichés：平均客户是一个五十多岁、在某个地方有秘密家庭的男人。可能是个同性恋情人，可能是个事实婚姻的妻子和一些孩子，但通常这些富豪们希望隐藏各种各样的秘密，而且他们还享有雇用他人秘密照料这些事情的特权。据我了解，为了这本书，你在18个国家进行了大约65次采访。跟我多讲讲你遇到的人吧。要成为一名财富管理师，你必须懂金融和法律，但这种角色也需要具备某种心理素质。什么样的人会成为财富管理师？
Well, several of the people I spoke to describe themselves in only somewhat joking terms as social workers for the rich. So you have to have empathy and a desire to help people, but also a very high tolerance for people who would otherwise seem to be so extremely privileged that you might be otherwise inclined to smack them around and say snap out of it. You're lucky. You write in your book about the extreme lengths that some managers go to please their clients or to provide services to their clients.
嗯，我交谈过的几个人用半开玩笑的口吻形容自己是富人的社工。所以你必须具备同理心和帮助他人的愿望，但同时也要对那些表现得极其特权、以至于你本来很想狠狠扇他们一巴掌并让他们清醒点的人保持极高的宽容度。你在书中写到了某些经理为了取悦客户或为客户提供服务而不惜采取的极端手段。
You write about a manager named Eleanor and, who said that one of her clients once called her from outside a restaurant in London. Tell me that story. So this is one of the first stories that I heard that really made my eyebrows raise. It was while I was training to be a wealth manager, Eleanor told this story over lunch of receiving a phone call from a client who was in another country saying, I've just lost my bracelet outside of a restaurant, helped me find it. And the client didn't identify the restaurant by name.
你写到了一位名叫埃莉诺的经理，她说过她的一个客户曾从伦敦一家餐厅外面给她打电话。给我讲讲那个故事吧。这是我听到的第一个真正让我感到惊讶的故事之一。当时我正在接受财富管理师的培训，埃莉诺在吃午饭时讲了这个故事：她接到一个身在异国的客户打来的电话，说：“我刚刚在一家餐厅外面把手镯弄丢了，快帮我找找。”而且客户并没有说出餐厅的名字。
So imagine having someone call you from another country. I mean, obviously the country was identified identified but not anything remotely approaching a location. So you have to sort of marvel at the immaturity of the client expecting someone else to help her fix a problem like this. But Eleanor somehow did it. She determined where the client was and what exactly had been lost
所以想象一下，有人从另一个国家打电话给你。我的意思是，很显然这个国家是知道的，但根本没有任何接近具体位置的信息。因此，你不得不对客户的这种不成熟感到惊叹，她竟然期望别人帮她解决这样的大麻烦。但埃莉诺不知怎么地做到了。她确定了客户当时在哪里以及具体丢了什么东西，
and got the local authorities on the case, found the bracelet and build the client for all the time and apparently the client was happy to pay. There are sometimes clients do make requests like this not because they are acting childish but because they actually have an ulterior motive. They actually want to test the loyalty or ability of the wealth wealth manager You tell the story of a wealth manager in Hong Kong named David. Yes, he got a call early on in his relationship with the client In which the client said that he was in Japan and he was Meeting with a Japanese gentleman who had expressed a desire for smoked salmon and that this client had promised him I think a thousand sides of smoked salmon straight from the factory in Scotland and was now calling David saying get me the salmon and David said well I'm your wealth manager not your fishmonger and the client said well today you're the fishmonger and so David
并让当地警方介入调查，找到了手镯，然后就所有花费的时间向客户开具了账单，显然客户也很乐意支付。有时候客户会提出这样的请求，并不是因为他们行为幼稚，而是因为他们实际上另有企图。他们其实是想测试财富管理师的忠诚度或能力。你讲了香港一个名叫大卫的财富管理师的故事。是的，他在与客户建立关系的初期接到过一个电话，客户在电话里说他在日本，
happens to know someone who knew the head of the smoke salmon factory in Scotland and he he fulfilled the client's wish. And the client later told him, I basically made up that story. I wasn't sitting across from a Japanese fellow who wanted a thousand sides of Smoksammon. I just needed to see that you had the connections and the will to do what I wanted when I wanted and not ask any questions. It was almost a test of his ability to jump and sort of perform this outlandish request, perhaps as a guide to sort of other requests that would come for the down the road. Exactly, and also it was a test of what kind of powerful social connections this wealth manager might have, because one of the wealth manager's roles is to set up private markets for deals. So it's not uncommon for them to have several clients, each of whom owns incredibly valuable
正与一位日本绅士会面，这位日本绅士表达了对熏三文鱼的渴望，而这位客户曾向他承诺过，我想是一千条直接来自苏格兰工厂的熏三文鱼侧片，现在正打电话给大卫说“给我弄来三文鱼”。大卫说“我是你的财富管理师，不是你的鱼贩”，而客户说“好吧，今天你就是鱼贩”。于是大卫
real estate, art collections, yachts, and so forth. And since these clients are very, very concerned about maintaining their privacy, they don't want to list these things on the open market for sale. If they need to raise cash, they want to do the sales as quietly as discreetly as possible with as little public recording as possible. One thing that I got from your book is that there are important ways in which the very rich are very much like the rest of us and ways in which they're not. So wealthy people, unsurprisingly, turn out to have troubled marriages and wayward children, just like everybody else.
碰巧认识一个了解苏格兰那家熏三文鱼工厂负责人的人，他满足了客户的愿望。客户后来告诉他：“我基本上是编造了那个故事。我当时并没有坐在一个想要一千条熏三文鱼侧片的日本人对面。我只是需要看看你是否有能力、有意志在我需要的时候做我想要的事情，而且不问任何问题。”这几乎是对他能否跃过门槛、完成这种离奇要求的能力的测试，或许可以作为未来可能出现的其他请求的指导。完全正确，这也是对这位财富管理师拥有何种强大社会关系的测试，因为财富管理师的角色之一就是为交易建立私人市场。因此，他们拥有好几位客户并不罕见，每位客户都拥有极其宝贵的
But wealth, you argue, can compound those challenges. Well, apparently it's not uncommon for the wealth manager to be asked to find or recommend rehab facilities for kids. Or a parent will ask a wealth manager to break some bad news to the next generation to his or her own children. Sometimes the wealth manager has to broker a truce between feuding family members. So one family member feels that they've been done by unfairly in the inheritance plan
房产、艺术品收藏、游艇等等。由于这些客户非常非常关心保护自己的隐私，他们不想把这些东西挂牌在公开市场上出售。如果他们需要筹集现金，他们希望尽可能安静、尽可能低调地进行销售，并尽可能减少公开记录。我从你的书里得到的一个感悟是，超级富豪与我们普通人在许多重要方面非常相似，但在某些方面又截然不同。不出所料，富人们也有着烦恼的婚姻和不听话的孩子，就像其他人一样。
and has to be somehow brought back in so that they don't sue the family. The big risk here is if you have a disgruntled family member who sews, the lawsuit process in many countries makes public many, many private documents that would reveal the extent and nature of a family's wealth, all of which have been carefully guarded secrets. When we come back, I'm going to talk to Brooke about how the rich lead very different lives than you and I. They don't just eat differently and travel differently and live in bigger
但你认为，财富会加剧这些挑战。嗯，显然，财富管理师被要求为孩子们寻找或推荐戒瘾所并不是什么新鲜事。或者父母会要求财富管理师向下一代、向他或她自己的孩子透露一些坏消息。有时财富管理师必须在争吵不休的家庭成员之间调停休战。所以某个家庭成员觉得他们在继承计划中受到了不公正的对待，
homes. They sometimes play by an entirely different set of rules. Stay with us. My guest today is a sociologist Brooke Harrington. She spent years trying to understand the lives of people who are so wealthy that they're able to circumvent the constraints of national laws and borders. In the course of her many interviews with wealth managers, Brooke talked to one professional in Switzerland who told her a revealing story. So this this wealth manager and her boss had been summons to a country outside of Europe by a client who was sending a private plane for them. She showed up at the Zurich airport with her boss waiting for this plane and she discovered that she'd left her passport back home in a different purse. And she said to her boss, I've got to go home and get my passport
必须想方设法让他们回归，以免他们起诉这个家族。这里的巨大风险在于，如果你有一个心怀不满并起诉的家庭成员，许多国家的诉讼程序会公开大量原本会暴露家族财富规模和性质的私密文件，而这些全都是精心保守的秘密。等我们回来后，我将与布鲁克谈谈富人们如何过着与你我截然不同的生活。他们不仅仅是吃得不同、旅行不同、住在更大的
because we're leaving Europe. And he said, don't worry about it. And she said, again, no, they're going to check my passport. They won't let me leave Switzerland, much less enter another country. I've got to go home and he said, no, really, don't worry about it. So she didn't say anything for their figuring, it would be his problem if she got refused the right to leave. Sure enough, the private plane pulls up, they get on it, nobody checks a passport.
房子里。他们有时完全按照一套截然不同的规则行事。请不要走开。我今天的嘉宾是社会学家布鲁克·哈灵顿。她花了好几年时间试图了解那些极其富有、以至于能够规避国家法律和边界约束的人的生活。在与财富管理师的多次采访过程中，布鲁克与瑞士的一位专业人士交谈，对方给她讲了一个意味深长的故事。这个财富管理师和她的老板被一个欧洲以外国家的客户传唤，客户派了一架私人飞机去接他们。她和老板一起出现在苏黎世机场等待这架飞机，却发现她的护照落在家里的另一个钱包里了。她对老板说：“我得回家去拿护照，
It lands in this other country outside Europe, nobody checks a passport, they get into the private car sent by the client, they're taken to the client's home, they have their meeting, private car takes them back to the private plane, private plane flies them back to Switzerland, they get off the plane and go home. At no point has anyone encountered passport control or a customs agent. And this wealth managers comment was, the lives of the richest people in the world are so different
因为我们要离开欧洲了。”而他说：“别担心。”她又说：“不，他们会检查我的护照的。他们不会让我离开瑞士，更不用说进入另一个国家了。我得回家。”他说：“不，真的，别担心。”于是她什么也没说，心想如果她被拒绝离开，那是他自己的问题。果不其然，私人飞机停了过来，他们登上了飞机，没有人检查护照。
from those of the rest of us. It's almost literally unimaginable. National borders are nothing to them. They might as well not exist. National borders are nothing to them. They might as well not exist. The laws are nothing to them. They might as well not exist. It's potentially very, very dangerous. And I think she's right about that.
飞机降落在欧洲以外的这个国家，没有人检查护照，他们坐上了客户派来的专车，被带到客户家中，开完会后，专车把他们送回私人飞机，私人飞机把他们飞回瑞士，他们下飞机回家。全程没有任何人遇到过边防海关或海关人员。这位财富管理师的评价是：“世界上最富有的人的生活与
You spoke with the wealth manager named Dieter. I think this was a German wealth manager who talked about how his job allowed him to shmuse with powerful people, but also in some ways discovered things about foreign countries before even the citizens of those countries would find out about those important things. Yeah, he was very proud of the fact that when he was working in Africa, he would have parties and the heads of state of the various countries he lived in would come to his house and he'd get them drunk, and they'd be spilling state secrets by two in the morning.
我们普通人的生活有着天壤之别。简直可以说是无法想象。国境对他们来说毫无意义。它们几乎可以说是不存在的。国境对他们来说毫无意义。它们几乎可以说是不存在的。法律对他们来说毫无意义。它们几乎可以说是不存在的。”这可能具有非常非常大的危险性。我认为她对此看法是正确的。
And then people like Catherine Graham, the late publisher of the Washington Post would call him up for advice. And you know, he could speak authoritatively about at least affairs in some African countries because he'd heard it directly from the mouths of the people who made those policies. It reminds me a little bit about what we learned when the Panama papers scandal broke. I kept seeing photos or drawings of the faces of people whose names turned up in the Panama papers and they were it was really a rogue's gallery of people from all walks of life as well as heads of state and corporate leaders. People who you would think have nothing
你采访了一位名叫迪特的财富管理师。我想这是一位德国财富管理师，他谈到他的工作如何让他能够与权贵们交际，但在某些方面，他甚至比那些国家的公民更早发现关于外国的重要事情。是的，他非常自豪的是，当他在非洲工作时，他会举办派对，他所居住的各个国家的国家元首都会来到他家，他会把他们灌醉，然后在凌晨两点时，他们就会吐露国家机密。
in common with each other. But at one level, the fact that they are so rich gives them these very important things in common, which is to say, for them, national boundaries and laws are all optional. Taxes are optional. All forms of law are essentially optional at that level of wealth. So this has come up recently in the US presidential election when Donald Trump suggested that not paying federal taxes or avoiding federal taxes legally, I might add, for several years, made him actually someone who was smart.
然后像《华盛顿邮报》已故出版人凯瑟琳·格雷厄姆这样的人会打电话向他征求建议。你知道的，他能够就某些非洲国家的事务进行权威的发言，因为他是直接从制定这些政策的人口中听到的。这让我想起了一点我们在“巴拿马文件”丑闻爆发时了解到的情况。我不断看到那些名字出现在“巴拿马文件”中的人物的面孔照片或画像，他们真的就是来自各行各业以及国家元首和企业领袖的无赖图库。那些你以为彼此毫无
He didn't pay any federal income tax. So if he paid zero, that means zero. As you tell me about these very rich people, drawn from different walks of life who have this thing in common, the fact they're very wealthy, talk a little bit about their attitude toward taxes, and their attitude and obligations in some ways to footing the common bill.
共同点的人。但在某种程度上，他们如此富有这一事实赋予了他们这些非常重要的共同点，也就是说，对他们而言，国境线和法律全都是可选的。税收是可选的。在那种财富水平下，所有形式的法律本质上都是可选的。所以这最近在美国总统大选中被提了出来，当时唐纳德·特朗普暗示，多年来不缴纳联邦税或合法避开联邦税（我得补充一下）实际上让他成了一个聪明人。
Some of them actually do sound a lot like Donald Trump. When I heard Donald Trump say that not paying taxes made him smart and that if he had paid his taxes, they would have been wasted anyways. I was like, yep, he's the voice of a lot of very wealthy people around the world and their wealth managers who said essentially the same thing to me. They are very committed to neoliberal ideology and very committed to the idea that these elite clients are doing the world a favor as, as wealth creators.
他没有支付任何联邦所得税。所以，如果他支付了零，那就意味着零。正如你向我讲述的这些来自各行各业、有着这一共同点（即他们非常富有）的超级富豪一样，请谈谈他们对待税收的态度，以及他们在某种程度上为公共账单出资的态度和义务。
And that their initiative should be protected against the, the governments and, and what they regard as theft by taxation, by incompetent governments that would just waste any money they collected anyways. They also, by the way, regard redistribution of collected tax as immoral, because it creates dependency on the part of the poor. So I'm fascinated because what you're saying is that,
其中一些人听起来确实很像唐纳德·特朗普。当我听到唐纳德·特朗普说不交税让他显得很聪明，而且如果他交了税，那些钱无论如何也会被浪费掉时，我想：是的，他就是全球许多超级富豪及其财富管理师的心声，他们对我也说过本质上完全相同的话。他们坚定地奉行新自由主义意识形态，坚信这些精英客户作为财富创造者是在为世界做贡献。
in effect, the wealthy and their tax managers don't just think they're doing something that's practical and expedient, you're saying they actually feel like they're doing the moral thing? There is a very strong component of ideology here and you see this in the wealth management training program, you see it among at least about a quarter of the people I interviewed really seem to believe quite unironically in the justice of protecting the wealth of their clients from taxation. They literally view taxation as theft and they view government in general as being incompetent at best, corrupt at worst, and they're deeply suspicious of any sort of welfare state programs because they see it as destroying initiative.
并且他们的首创精神应该受到保护，免受政府以及他们所认为的由无能政府通过税收进行的盗窃的侵害，因为无能政府无论如何都会浪费他们收取的任何资金。顺便说一句，他们还认为重新分配所征收的税款是不道德的，因为它会造成穷人的依赖性。所以我感到很着迷，因为你的意思是，
So the picture you've painted for me broke of the wealth manager, someone who is a loyal person, an honest person, a resourceful person, trustworthy, and I fully imagine that lots of wealthy people are probably very good people, high-minded people, but I want to talk for a moment about the professionals whose clients are very clearly, you know, sleaze bags. How do you as a wealth manager serve the interests of someone who is cheating his country on taxes, cheating on his wife, cheating his employees? How do you serve a client like that and then go home, tell yourself that you're a good person and sleep well at night?
实际上，富人及其税务经理不仅认为他们在做一些务实和权宜的事情，你是说他们实际上觉得自己在做一件符合道德的事？这里有一个非常强烈的意识形态成分，你在财富管理培训项目中可以看到这一点，你在我采访的至少大约四分之一的人身上也能看到这一点，他们似乎非常不带讽刺意味地坚信保护客户财富免受税收侵害的正义性。他们字面意义上将税收视为偷窃，并且普遍认为政府最好也就是无能，最坏则是腐败，他们对任何形式的福利国家程序都深表怀疑，因为他们认为这会摧毁进取心。
Well, some of them don't, and I think that's one of the reasons why we're seeing a wave of leaks recently, that some people are so troubled by what they're seeing that they just can't stomach it any longer, and they blow the whistle, often with dire personal consequences. About a quarter of the people I interviewed, I would characterize as being conscious stricken about the larger impacts of their work. And they had a range of strategies to reconcile themselves, to the implications of that for their own conscience. One of the ways that they dealt with it
所以布鲁克，你为我描绘的财富管理师的形象是一个忠诚、诚实、机智、值得信赖的人，而且我完全可以想象，许多富人可能都是非常好的人、高尚的人，但我想花点时间谈谈那些客户很明显是卑鄙小人的专业人士。作为一名财富管理师，你如何为逃税、出轨、欺骗员工的人服务？你如何为这样的客户服务，然后回家告诉自己你是个好人，晚上能睡个好觉？
was to encourage their clients to donate to charity, to offset the negative impact of depriving the state of revenues. Other people I interviewed, including one gentleman in Panama City, said he would actually lecture his clients on the work of a Marchus N and Joseph Stiglitz, basically on the theory and practice of inequality in the world. And he would point out to them that as they sat in his office in Panama City, a couple miles away, people were living in cardboard shacks and had no access to clean drinking water.
嗯，有些人做不到，我认为这就是为什么我们最近看到一波泄密潮的原因之一，有些人对他们所看到的一切感到如此困扰，以至于他们再也无法忍受，于是他们选择吹哨，通常会带来可怕的个人后果。我采访过的人中，大约有四分之一可以被描述为对他们工作的更大影响感到良心不安。他们有一系列策略来调和这些影响与他们自己的良知。他们处理这件事的方法之一
And what did the client think about that? Now, that may seem mild, but it's a fairly risky strategy to pursue with wealthy people who are used to having people fall over them and not challenge them. And frankly, most wealth managers are replaceable. There aren't a lot of them in the world, but if you find one a little too in your face, you could always go get another one or get another one within a different company. I think a lot of people have impressions of the lives of the very wealthy and imagine what
就是鼓励他们的客户向慈善机构捐款，以抵消剥夺国家财政收入的负面影响。我采访的其他人，包括巴拿马城的一位绅士，说他实际上会给他的客户讲授阿马蒂亚·森和约瑟夫·斯蒂格利茨的著作，基本上是关于世界上不平等现象的理论与实践。他会向他们指出，当他们坐在他巴拿马城的办公室里时，几英里外，人们正住在纸板搭的简易房里，没有干净的饮用水。
life must be like when you're jetting around in a private plane and being waited on by service staff all the time. And I'm wondering in your conversations with wealth managers, whether any of your own assumptions or beliefs about the connections between wealth and happiness were either confirmed or challenged? I was struck by a man I spoke to in the Channel Islands who talked about how suspicious wealthy people are. It jibed with some things that I've seen personally. And what he said was, when you're really wealthy, it's not uncommon to have the experience that everyone is out to get a piece of you. It's like what happens to a lot of our winners, all sorts of so-called
客户对此怎么看？现在，这听起来可能很温和，但对于那些习惯了别人对他们阿谀奉承、从不挑战他们的富人来说，这是一种相当冒险的策略。坦率地说，大多数财富管理师都是可以被替代的。世界上并不缺这样的人，但如果你觉得某个管理师有点太针锋相对了，你总可以换一个，或者在另一家公司换一个。我想很多人对超级富豪的生活都有所印象，想象着当你坐着私人飞机四处飞、时时刻刻都有服务人员伺候时，生活该是什么样子的。我想知道，在你与财富管理师的对话中，你关于财富与幸福之间关系的任何假设或信念是否得到了证实或挑战？我为一个在海峡群岛跟我交谈过的人所深深打动，他谈到了富人们是多么疑神疑鬼。这与我个人所看到的一些情况不谋而合。他说的是，当你真正富有的时候，有一种经历并不少见，那就是每个人都想从你身上捞到一点好处。这就像我们许多中奖者身上发生的情况一样，各种所谓的
relatives come out of the woodwork, asking for loans, asking for help of some sort. Con artists come out of the woodwork, looking to get a piece of you. But that's what happens throughout the lifetime of wealthy people. And so it breeds a kind of suspicion. Why do you want to be my friend? Why are you being nice to me? Are you just trying to get me to give you something?
亲戚从各个角落冒出来，借钱，寻求某种帮助。骗子从各个角落冒出来，想要从你身上分一杯羹。但在富人的一生中，这种情况不断发生。因此，它滋生了一种猜疑。你为什么想和我交朋友？你为什么对我这么好？你是不是只是想让我给你什么东西？
And that must be very unpleasant. And you can see how that would lead at the extreme to a sort of Howard Husey and retreat or isolation from people, because if you can't trust anyone, why bother? I mean, the sad thing that you're saying is that the wealth manager might end up being perhaps among the very few people that a rich person can trust. Yeah, I think that seems to be a common story. It's wealthy people and their servants.
那一定非常令人不快。你可以看出这在极端情况下是如何导致霍华德·休斯式的隐居或与人群隔绝的，因为如果你不能信任任何人，又何必去费心呢？我的意思是，你所说的悲惨之处在于，财富管理师最终可能成为富人能够信任的极少数人之一。是的，我想这似乎是一个常见的叙事。这就是富人和他们的仆人。
It almost comes to the point where you can, if you're a wealthy person, you are more trusting of the people you pay to be in your service than the people you don't pay because with your family you might have sort of a kinglier problem, which of my children actually loves me and which are out to get something from me. But at least when you are having a transactional relationship with an employee, at least the boundaries there are clear. You're paying them for certain services, and you can assess whether they are giving you
事情几乎发展到这种地步：如果你是一个富人，你比那些不拿你钱的人更信任你花钱雇来为你服务的人，因为对于你的家人，你可能会遇到一种更痛苦的问题：我的哪个孩子是真的爱我，哪个孩子是从我这里图谋东西。但至少当你和员工发生交易关系时，那里的界限是清晰的。你为某些服务付钱给他们，你可以评估他们是否在以你要求的标准为你提供
those services at the standard you require. If they're not, you fire them. If they're doing a good job, you keep them on. There's a simplicity to that that is not present in emotional relationships. Brooke Harrington is a sociologist at the Copenhagen Business School in Denmark. She's the author of the book Capital Without Borders, Wealth Managers, and the 1%. Brooke, I want to thank you for talking with me today. Thank you. This week's show was produced by Maggie Penman and Parts Cha. Our team includes Tara Boyle, Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen and Renee Clark. This week our unsung hero is Michael Cullen. Michael is one of NPR's audio
这些服务。如果他们没有，你就解雇他们。如果他们做得好，你就留用他们。这其中有一种情感关系中所不存在的简单性。布鲁克·哈灵顿是丹麦哥本哈根商学院的社会学家。她是《无国界资本：财富管理师与1%的人》一书的作者。布鲁克，我想感谢你今天与我交谈。谢谢你。本期节目由玛吉·彭南曼和帕茨·查制作。我们的团队包括塔拉·博伊尔、珍妮·施密特、雷娜·科恩和雷妮·克拉克。本周我们的幕后英雄是迈克尔·卡伦。迈克尔是NPR的音频
engineers and the person who seems to know how to solve every technical challenge we have. This week he spends several hours troubleshooting our connection to the Danish studio where Brok Harrington is based. Michael, thanks for fixing our technical woes with such a kind and calm demeanor. We really appreciate it. If you liked this episode, please make sure you are subscribed to this podcast and please tell a friend who might enjoy this show. I'm Shankar Vidantam and this is NPR.
工程师之一，也是那个似乎知道如何解决我们遇到的所有技术难题的人。本周他花了几个小时排查我们与布鲁克·哈灵顿所在的丹麦工作室之间的连接故障。迈克尔，感谢你以如此亲切和冷静的态度解决我们的技术难题。我们真的很感激。如果你喜欢这期节目，请确保你订阅了本节目，并请把节目推荐给可能喜欢它的朋友。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。
We are. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是。该剧集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。